DAVE HAZLEBECK: So this is
the dried algae product.
After we dry it, we
grind it up into powder,
and then we extract
the oil out of it.
That oil is then refined
into diesel fuel or jet fuel.
The fuel that we're producing
is exactly the same,
in terms of performance as
gasoline, or diesel, or jet.
It's just a lot cleaner.
And I think the
big difference is
that all the other
biofuels, you're growing it,
you're just getting biofuel.
In this case, every
gallon of biofuel,
you get 10 pounds
of food with it.
NARRATOR: Dave Hazlebeck is the
CEO and founder of Global Algae
Innovations, a San Diego
based company growing algae
on a farm in Hawaii,
which he thinks
could change the landscape
of food and oil production.
DAVE HAZLEBECK:
There are studies
that show with algae
grown to replace
a large percentage
of animal feed,
you could actually solve global
warming to a large extent,
simply by doing that.
Second thing is that the
leading cause of global water
impairment is runoff
from agriculture.
When we grow algae,
there's no runoff.
All the nutrients are
captured in the algae.
Environmentally is
for deforestation,
the leading cause
of deforestation
is for food production.
With algae producing
40 times more per acre,
that means if we
plant 1,000 acres
of algae, that's
40,000 acres of crops
that don't need to be planted.
But the work here we're
doing is extremely important.
The world desperately
needs algae biofuels
and algae protein production.
It's going to have a
big impact economically,
it's going to have a big impact
on reducing poverty, improving
standards of living,
because it'll create jobs
and revenue in rural areas.
That's why I decided
to start this company,
so that it could happen
quickly, because it's
too important for the
world for it not to happen.
So we're standing
right now in one
of our larger algae raceways.
This is about a 2 acre
raceway, but these raceways
can be scaled to much larger.
We look at making individual
raceways up to 200 acres.
And this is next
to a power plant.
That's unique,
because that allows
us to capture carbon dioxide
and avoid that discharge,
and reuse it.
And that prevents it from
going into the atmosphere
and causing global warming.
If every power plant had
an algae farm next to it,
it could potentially solve the
global warming issue entirely.
NARRATOR: In simple terms,
algae is fairly easy to grow,
and it's able to flourish
just about anywhere,
whether it be freshwater,
seawater, or brackish water.
All it really needs is a good
supply of carbon dioxide,
and plenty of sunshine.
And while the location of Global
Algae Innovations in Hawaii
makes sense, Hazlebeck's team
come across some obstacles
trying to scale the process up.
DAVE HAZLEBECK: You can see with
all these tremendous benefits,
you know, why aren't we doing
it now, and why hasn't it done?
The problem is
that the costs are
too high throughout
the entire process,
and so it really requires
hundreds of innovations
throughout the entire process
in order to reduce the cost,
because it's about
10 times too high.
NARRATOR: The problem associated
with large scale production
has put similar companies
out of business,
but the approach of Global
Algae Innovations is different.
Instead of seeing a roadblock,
Hazlebeck and his team
saw the potential to
innovate solutions.
DAVE HAZLEBECK: Our approach
was different in that we looked
at every single step,
developed a model,
we looked at the costs.
And the other thing is we didn't
give up on any critical issues.
So a gallon of oil
when we started
would have been
about $30 a gallon.
Now, with the innovations we've
made over the last few years,
we're down in the range of
$2.00 to $3.00 a gallon,
as a projected cost.
Now, we're not there yet from
the standpoint of production,
but depending on how
fast we can get to scale,
we could potentially
have solutions
within the next few years.
And that's really exciting.
It'll change the
geopolitics of the world.
A lot of the
reasons we have wars
are because of fights
over resources.
And by creating a more
equitable distribution,
with countries being
able to make their own,
it should lead to a more
stable and peaceful world.
NARRATOR: Algae biofuel
could potentially
be used in engines
that we already have,
and there would be no additional
infrastructure needed,
as it would be available
at your local gas station.
DAVE HAZLEBECK: As we
develop technology,
we plan to partner
with lots of people
to have it expand
in other areas.
We're not trying to be the
only company doing this,
because we're in it
because of the impact.
I always talk with
our team, what
they're doing is going to
change the entire world,
in the sense of both the
protein and the oil production.
Because both are
desperately needed.
NARRATOR: To hear more
about the science of algae
being made into biofuel, check
out this episode of D News.
SUBJECT 1: Biofuels like
these are energy sources that
come from living matter.
They stand apart from fossil
fuels which, by the way,
also come from living matter,
because biofuels are made now,
not over millions of years.
SUBJECT 2: Takes a lot of time
to grow a whole field of corn,
but to grow out a lot of
algae is a lot faster,
and it's just a plant.
NARRATOR: Thanks for
watching Seeker Stories,
and be sure to subscribe
for new videos every week.